[Music]
in young lovers news young love of baby
it's nice to be young and loving you
have a baby in you alright if you're
pregnant you're still [ __ ] sexy and
horny yeah Tellem and with your mom but
I don't want the dick hitting the baby's
head it's in a sack yeah nowhere near
that yeah but the sack is still like all
dicks ain't that big
alright look oh you're gonna show me
right okay I'm gonna show you something
you don't know nothing about Anatomy in
your imagination is where's the baby is
it in its a core is it just kicking it
next to all your other baby if the baby
is in its correct form its upside down
with the head down here with the mouth
open Wow how many weeks you go there oh
well because it's feeding on the
amniotic fluid no it doesn't feed
through the mouth though it feeds from
stupid that's you know jack-shit okay I
thought the kid was just yours
I don't know the time for an apology
major but baby's head is down here okay
in the pelvic region right but mine
isn't there's a [ __ ] sack that
covers this area right all it takes is a
little bit of dick to go from here to
here to smack the baby in the face okay
well since you're the uncle I'll let you
know that the baby's positioning is not
there yet so we're good so she's getting
[ __ ] in the ass that's all no continue
I think is coming you know maybe you
should do it because then the baby could
be good at fighting the eyes are still
getting ready
Justice miles getting jadon the face
doesn't know what it is maybe a good
fighter six pence now all right
submitted by JK I see you a
fourteen-year-old boy may have to
register as a sex offender after having
sex with his 12 year old girlfriend
but that's regular normal stuff isn't it
you were having sex every teen who was
that first I had friends that were
[ __ ] at 14 that says I'll [ __ ] it at
12 but it just sucks yes a register as a
sex offender that's not fair well my 18
year old my Wow
oh wait the girl didn't want it no it
was consensual
that's not fair the pit really depends
on how fast you grow up it doesn't
really matter about the sign up though
at the age of 14
you should not be canoodling with 12
year olds really it is kind of weird did
you kick it with a bunch of 12 girls
when you were 14 no it is a 12 year old
sixth grader
yeah no high school and the six people
visit so I know that the 14 year old is
in the seventh grade okay
dumbass Bob okay work what you know the
seventh grade I thought 14 was a third I
was 14 in seventh grade I was fourteen
nine ninth grade 14 you're suppose to be
in high school
ah 13 14 is Russian 95 yeah this one's a
US of A yeah Tecna stupido fourth
so he's in freshman with a seventh or
eighth grader no so they're saying that
this fourteen-year-old boy is an
unidentified seventh grader at 14 oh so
he was just [ __ ] his classmate he was
[ __ ] a 12 year old yeah but but
twelve retired seventh grade they should
be six or so they're probably they're
probably is just his classmate but my
point that I'm trying to make though is
that he's dumb as [ __ ]
oh he's done his [ __ ] cuz he's 14 at
seventh grade
he's won twice should be in 10th grade
he should be in about like either a
freshman freshman on going to a
sophomore like yeah eighth grader
freshman I felt bad should be call this
kid dumb battle know what you bastard
that's for
and I was a freshman hey he might be
dumb but he got some [ __ ] that's all
that matters in life honestly not [ __ ]
but just being happy so he's pursuing
his dreams he's in love alright
classmate that's not fair
if they're both in 7/8 man I don't know
about that because is it his fault that
he's dumb as rocks and it's consensual
oh yes to register as a sex offender
he's only 14 that's [ __ ] up
let's not even say 14 anymore he's a
seventh Christmas yes seventh grade this
is a concept there yeah and he had just
turned 14 I believe like too much yeah
by two months he had just turned 14 so
that's important so he was 13 or maybe
his birthdays like really late in the
year it's not that late mine is in
October
same as my sister hers is in December
that makes us younger right come on
November the youngest is the we are
young as me is the girl the 14 year old
total 12 y/o the girls have a sec super
early girl but it depends on how fast
you go I knew people that were blasting
people driving when they're 12 it
doesn't make it right it doesn't make it
right but it's reality depend on where
you are and the standards of that region
yes
vanished a dear friend of the rear of
the house in my house you haven't you
[ __ ] at 12 you old enough to get a
job man huh the [ __ ] out of here well
your monkey was [ __ ] at 12 okay it's
like that you know when you first
started fun huh I was 18 I lost my very
long 18 years a job because my junior
how do your job my junior high had a
baby City Place and there were two girls
in my class might two two of the girls
in my seventh grade class they brought
their kids to school with them and they
would drop the kids off over there so
these these kids are already like two
years old kid why does something so
[ __ ] pop out something so pure and
cute it's because some girls have a
period when they're eight yeah that was
my sister that's what I'm saying it
depends on how it's not right but it
depends on how fast you grow that's true
cuz Mexican girls are potent ah
zing we are now we're not dumpsters we
collect that [ __ ] oh come collectors
like base point we're not boarding the
sperm up in there anyway took a wrong
turn you know I could come into the air
and then the [ __ ] mist of the
confirmation so in Texas there's there
is this so-called Romeo and Juliet law
that allows that allows kids aged 14 15
16 and 17 to have sex with someone
that's within 3 years of age of their
age does that make sense
up and down older and younger no younger
that sounds pretty fair to me actually
yeah but this excludes if you're younger
than 14 Oh count this law does Romeo and
Juliet won't count so after a 14 it has
to be with another 14 year old exactly
or older up to 7 but what if you're dumb
as rocks and everyone in your class is 2
years under the new that's why there's
like continuation school like you really
got it once that kid flumps like sixth
grade twice it's like okay you we still
got to advance you but now you need to
take separate classes for you to catch
up that's what normally happens you
don't keep a [ __ ] 14 round 12 year
olds [ __ ] school you've dumb [ __ ]
yeah so you had just turned 14 two
months before this whole ordeal happened
and I'm not sure exactly how he got
caught or they got caught in the act but
apparently they got caught it's pretty
easy on me they're teens
did you want to have sex with your 1219
no this one's gonna graduate when you're
18 or 20 years old all those in the
horny when I was 12 how old are you when
you're 12 let me know yeah the
girlfriend's in sick
grade two as well so so yeah so they're
saying since it doesn't qualify for them
because the girl is 12 years old so
that's under the age of 14
yeah thing there is a possibility that
you will have to register as a sex
offender because that law doesn't
qualify for him but they are saying that
in that County they use some [ __ ]
common sense yes they do oh cool
so it doesn't seem like you will like
that will happen to him but just the
possibility of it happening it got
reported and it just spread like
wildfire in the media and that's what
we're talking about it today that's nice
that they have common sense but he
should not be he should have already
advanced like I know it's like dumb for
people to think that a little if he's
not smart enough but like I said that's
why there's like what's it called
programs out there where they get you to
catch up a lot of the way because you
can't have like 14 15 or 12 year olds it
doesn't work like that you're not
supposed to do that especially around
especially around that age because
you're like you can't have like a
six-foot man with like cuz there's some
people that are 14 or 86 feet tall and
you can't have him with people that are
just entering puberty my freshman friend
his name is Paul Paul yeah and he was
bigger than the teachers and he was
really big and I was I was really happy
you hung out with us a lot because he
was like our bodyguard remember that man
we met in Hawaii in the supermarket oh
yeah that that big girl right oh the
news she's like yeah yeah holy great
she's taller than you dude shoot like
Sir John 14 yeah I know but she was big
though but she was in a sports play that
she liked softball or some [ __ ] like
that
yeah taller than you know maybe not
taller than me but she was coffee she
was seventh grade
yeah seventh grade she was pretty good
she should probably be smaller than her
like if she pushed me in my chest
something with came in my she was too
strong
yeah so the mom of the little boy he she
ended up saying quote he had consensual
sex with his little girlfriend and he
loved her and because he turned 14 they
want to make him a six
under put him on the registry with
pedophiles and child abusers really sick
and dangerous people that's what she
said that's true yeah I think they
should not do well she's like he's going
about sex anyway let him have sex mmm
you shouldn't really they shouldn't
really be [ __ ] at that age they
shouldn't what they shouldn't be [ __ ]
at that age what would be the
appropriate jackoff huh what would be
the appropriate age to have sex the age
when you can deal with having [ __ ]
AIDS mentally you're on this aids theme
oh yeah I know but nobody knows because
every video is different and it's
released in different times so now hunt
for those videos but one is I think
everybody likes [ __ ] but can we deal
with the consequence he is your [ __ ]
12 how's a kid gonna raise a kid because
sometimes they back out they go out I
can't go through with this and even if
they go with the abortion their minds
not ready to [ __ ] deal with the
stress that adults can't deal with what
what you know with an abortion so it
[ __ ] them up mentally and stuff like
that so I think if you comment' be
mentally prepared and mature and strong
enough then you're ready to [ __ ] yeah
cuz I deal with the consequences cuz I
think like as a parent too like let's
say your kid 16 I don't know 15 years
old has it you know they're gonna have a
kid right that's not fair to me I just
got done raising you [ __ ] [ __ ] now that
I raised your [ __ ] kid to [ __ ] that
kid I love them Mike you know grandkid
but other than that that's like that
sucks for me like I put in all this time
and effort for you and I'm already I'm
spent now now you could feed yourself
you could drive yourself places I'm done
I'm done
I just gotta guide you nah man you got a
[ __ ] little [ __ ] [ __ ] walking
around pissing all over the place okay
[ __ ] gross manage I deal with that
it's not fair on me Oh see I'm already
mad at my kid and they're even born yet
I'm already here hey guys hope you
enjoyed that episode please don't miss a
beat and subscribe because if you don't
subscribe you don't know when a new
video is uploaded but for more videos
up here
[Music]